Jake: 然后一个秒表
Jake: Okay, then we need a stopwatch.
Shure:  时间戳呗
Shure: Mark a timestamp, right?
Jake: 戳一下
Jake: Mark it.
Jake: 都戳一下
Jake: Everyone, mark it.
Jake: 每人戳一下
Jake: Each person, mark it.
Jake: 传过去戳一下哎
Jake: Pass it around and mark it.
Jake: 你能看到对吗
Jake: You can see it, right?
Jake: 好戳完了
Jake: Alright, all marked.
Jake: 行
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 开机开
Jake: Turn it on.
Jake: 那
Jake: So,
Jake:就是今天我们就讨论讨论
Jake: Today, we will discuss,
Jake: 早上讨论
Jake: Discuss this morning.
Jake: 讨论我们最后一天干点啥呗
Jake: Discuss what we will do on our last day.
Jake: 然后可能
Jake: And then maybe,
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 就是这边还有4个
Jake: There are still four of these.
Jake: 这个USB就可能这
Jake: This USB, maybe this.
Jake: 这叫什么
Jake: What's this called?
Jake: 这个硬盘
Jake: This hard drive.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 早上我觉得大家主要是讨论
Jake: This morning, I think we mainly discuss.
Jake: 然后讨论的时候闲着没事
Jake: And when discussing, if there's nothing to do.
Jake: 如果大家陷入了沉思
Jake: If everyone falls into deep thought.
Jake: 陷入了尴尬
Jake: If it gets awkward.
Jake: 可以把这个给装一装
Jake: We can put this together.
Jake: 对只是一个back up
Jake: Yeah, just as a backup.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 所以
Jake: So,
Jake: 现在就尴尬了啊
Jake: Now it's awkward, huh?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure: 先看拆了看看是什么
Shure: Let's first open it and see what it is.
Jake: 行那也行那也行
Jake: Okay, that's fine too.
Shure:  哇哦
Shure: Wow.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 只有4个吗
Lucia: Only four?
Jake: 对只有4个
Jake: Yes, only four.
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia: 我拆过这个
Lucia: I've taken this apart before.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake: 因为你是menter
Jake: Because you are the mentor.
Jake: 啊对
Jake: Oh, right.
Lucia: tutor
Lucia: Tutor.
Lucia: 哈哈我已经装过这个东西了
Lucia: Haha, I've already assembled this thing.
Shure:  需要充电宝在这里拿
Shure: If you need a power bank, take one here.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Jake: 我先把这些端走
Jake: I'll take these away first.
Katrina:  哇还有螺丝呀
Jake: Wow, there are screws too.
Jake: 大家拆出来了可以摆成什么样呢
Jake: What can we make after taking everything apart?
Jake: 摆成
Jake: Make it...
Jake: 这个盒子要留着
Jake: We need to keep this box.
Jake: 嗯里边这个东西可以丢掉
Jake: Hmm, the stuff inside can be thrown away.
Jake: 这东西都丢掉吧
Jake: Let's throw all this stuff away.
Jake: 这眼镜布留着
Jake: Keep this glasses cloth.
Jake: 好那就先摆成这样
Jake: Okay, let's just arrange it like this for now.
Jake: 这个是等大家陷入沉思的时候再用
Jake: This will be used when everyone is deep in thought.
Jake: 但是这个我可以跟大家先讲一下
Jake: But I can explain it to you all now.
Jake: 这个东西是什么呢
Jake: What is this thing?
Jake: 就大家可以看这个地方
Jake: So everyone can look at this part.
Jake: 你们也看不见这个地方
Jake: You can't see this part either.
Jake: 或者你们过来吧
Jake: Or you can come over.
Jake: 走动走动
Jake: Walk around.
Jake: 就是看我的工作间
Jake: Just look at my workspace.
Shure:  我们这算私闯闺房吗
Shure: Are we intruding into private space?
Jake: 那请请请请
Jake: Please, please, please, please.
Jake: 工作间
Jake: Workspace.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake: 然后这7台
Jake: Then there's seven.
Jake: 8台
Jake: Eight.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 9台 10台
Jake: Nine, ten.
Jake: 但是就是这边6台电脑
Jake: But we have six computers here.
Jake: 每一个电脑
Jake: Each computer
Jake: 都对应着你们的一台眼镜
Jake: corresponds to one of your glasses.
Jake: 然后这个每一台电脑
Jake: Then each computer
Jake: 你们每次录完结束
Jake: after you finish recording
Jake: 每隔三个小时
Jake: every three hours
Jake: 然后会嗯就是在这儿导到这个硬盘里边
Jake: will import the data into this hard drive.
Jake: 然后这个硬盘
Jake: Then this hard drive
Jake: 就是你们一会要装的硬盘
Jake: is the one you need to install later.
Jake: 就是比方说这个这个L1这个L1这个L2
Jake: For example, this L1, this L1, and this L2,
Jake: 然后这个名字的名字都写在这了
Jake: the names are all written here.
Jake: 哈哈哈你们的数据都在这个里边
Jake: Haha, all your data is in here.
Jake: 这我们的第二生命
Jake: This is our second life.
Jake: 比方说我这个L1
Jake: For example, my L1,
Jake: 对吧然后你们结束之后
Jake: right? And after you finish,
Jake: 就是会把这个眼镜插到这个上面
Jake: 然后同时
Jake: And at the same time,
Jake: 现在一直接着这个第一个硬盘
Jake: now continuously connect to this first hard drive.
Jake: 对然后这个硬盘它有两根线
Jake: Yes, and this hard drive has two cables.
Jake: 一个是一个是接电脑的
Jake: One connects to the computer,
Jake: 一个是接电源的
Jake: one connects to the power.
Jake: 然后这个电源
Jake: Then this power
Jake: 是为了让这个硬盘假装自己在电脑上
Jake: is to make the hard drive pretend it's connected to a computer.
Jake:呵呵 所以这个盒的意思就是说
Jake: Haha, so this box means
Jake: 他给模拟一个电脑的环境
Jake: it simulates a computer environment.
Shure: 诱骗器
Shure: A decoy.
Jake: 然后用硬盘对对
Jake: And using the hard drive, yes.
Jake:对对 让硬盘能知道自己要工作了
Jake: Yes, so the hard drive knows it needs to work.
Jake: 对啊然后这个线啊
Jake: Yeah, and this cable,
Jake: 这个线我们我们布线还挺有意思的
Jake: this cable, we set it up quite interestingly.
Jake: 就长成这个样子
Jake: It looks like this.
Jake: 呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Jake: 呵呵是一个悬着的
Jake: Haha, it's hanging there.
Shure: 是一个悬着的啊
Shure: It's hanging there, huh?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 那如果突然停电了会怎么样
Shure: What if there's a sudden power outage?
Jake: 那不好讲
Jake: That's hard to say.
Jake: 就是电脑突然停电
Jake: Like if the computer suddenly loses power.
Jake: 就是会很尴尬
Jake: It would be really awkward.
Shure:  那没有什么
Shure: Is there nothing like...
Shure:  就是USP之类的
Shure: Like a USP or something?
Shure:  嗯就是那种备用电源
Shure: You know, like a backup power supply.
Jake: 哦哦没有
Jake: Oh, no.
Jake: 还没那么有钱
Jake: We're not that rich yet.
Jake: 我们只能相信这个别墅
Jake: We just have to trust this villa.
Jake: 或者相信北京电力吧
Jake: Or trust the Beijing power company.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yep.
Shure:  感谢
Shure: Thanks.
Jake: 好你们都开始装了
Jake: Alright, you guys start setting up.
Shure:  我们
Shure: We...
Shure:  我们可以
Shure: We can...
Jake:可以边聊边装嘛
Jake: We can talk while setting up?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Jake: 对嗯或者说你们先带你们带点什么吧
Jake: Sure, or maybe you can show us what you brought.
Jake: 你们带点什么
Jake: What did you bring?
Jake: 哎这个这个眼镜你得带好
Jake: Hey, these glasses, you need to put them on right.
Jake: 这眼镜
Jake: These glasses.
Jake: 嗯也不能遮住
Jake: Yeah, don't cover them.
Jake: 应该都不没遮住吧
Jake: They shouldn't be covered, right?
Jake: 现在没遮住
Jake: They're not covered now.
Lucia:  但这里有一个孔
Jake: But there's a hole here.
Lucia: 然后这个地方是要坐在这的
Lucia: And this part needs to sit here.
Lucia: 所以你要就是最好这样对齐
Lucia: So you should align it like this.
Lucia: 然后慢慢往里推
Lucia: And then slowly push it in.
Lucia: 看怎么样能推进去
Lucia: See how it fits in.
Lucia: 好像要轻一点
Lucia: It needs to be gentle.
Lucia: 那天那同学跟我说这个挺脆弱的
Lucia: That classmate told me this is quite fragile.
Jake: 嗯对就是
Jake: Yeah, exactly.
Jake: 没事搞定
Jake: No worries, got it.
Lucia: 就是这不是有一个口吗
Lucia: There's this notch, right?
Lucia: 跟这个是对着的
Lucia: It aligns with this.
Lucia: 你就像他们这样对着
Lucia: Just like them, face it like this.
Lucia: 然后慢慢地推
Lucia: And then push slowly.
Lucia: 看这样手里能有推进去
Lucia: See if you can push it in with your hand.
Lucia: 要稍微使点力气
Lucia: You need to use a bit of force.
Lucia: 他这还是有一点紧的
Lucia: It's still a bit tight.
Lucia: 但是需要别太使劲
Shure: But don't use too much force.
Lucia: 别掰坏了
Lucia: Don't break it.
Shure:  没有吧
Shure: I don't think so.
Lucia: 好像很脆弱的样子
Lucia: It looks very fragile.
Lucia: 不过我其实也不是很懂这个
Lucia: But actually, I don't really understand this.
Jake: 有有有很多螺丝
Jake: There are many screws.
Lucia: 要拧螺丝
Lucia: We need to tighten the screws.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 那螺丝呢
Shure: What about the screws?
Lucia: 在那里面
Lucia: They’re in there.
Shure:  哦懂了
Jake: Oh, got it.
Shure:  easy
Shure: Easy.
Katrina:  然后就把它装进去了
Katrina: And then we just put it in.
Lucia: 嗯对然后要装到这个盒子里
Lucia: Yeah, and then it needs to go into this box.
Lucia: 就是你最好是把这个地方取下来
Lucia: You should probably take this part off first.
Lucia: 然后这个片就可以不要了
Lucia: And then you can discard this piece.
Lucia: 因为这里一会要也要用来拧螺丝
Lucia: Because we’ll need this spot to screw in later.
Alice: 是不是只要拧4个螺丝啊
Alice: Do we just need to screw in 4 screws?
Lucia: 呃8个
Lucia: Uh, 8.
Alice:：：8个吗
Alice: 8?
Lucia: 对.
Lucia: 就是你你把那个条抽出来
Lucia: Yeah, you need to pull out that strip.
Lucia: 对然后就你看到那个孔了没
Lucia: Right, and then you see that hole?
Lucia: 长条形那个
Lucia: The long one.
Lucia: 他那里面也有一个螺丝孔
Lucia: There's a screw hole in there too.
Lucia: 你要把那个也上上
Lucia: You need to screw that one in too.
Lucia: 就是那个是大螺丝的螺丝孔
Lucia: That's the screw hole for the big screw.
Alice:：啊哪个
Katrina: Uh, which one?
Lucia: 呃这一个
Lucia: Uh, this one.
Alice:：我已经上上完一个螺丝
Alice: I've already screwed in one.
Lucia: 就是这个这个东西
Lucia: It's this thing.
Lucia: 嗯我怎么样给你指的比较清楚
Lucia: Hmm, how do I point it out more clearly to you?
Lucia: 哎你上的这是对的
Lucia: Ah, you got it right.
Alice: 嗯
Lucia: 对然后这边每个都有
Lucia: Yes, and there's one on each side.
Lucia: 然后这个也是所以一共是8个
Lucia: And this one too, so there are 8 in total.
Lucia: 对的
Lucia: Exactly.
Alice:：嗷懂了
Alice: Oh, got it.
Alice: 看见了
Alice: I see.
Katrina:  看见了这是大螺丝
Katrina: I see, this is the big screw.
Lucia: 这是大螺丝
Lucia: This is the big screw.
Alice:：没看见刚刚
Alice: Didn't see it just now.
Katrina:  你看在这
Katrina: Look, it's here.
Lucia: 对对小螺丝上这对
Lucia: Yes, the small screws go here.
Alice: 哦里边是把它插进去就行了吧
Alice: Oh, you just insert it in, right?
Alice: 就那个
Alice: Just that one.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Alice: 呃那个对
Alice: Uh, that one, right.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia: 里面应该插进去
Lucia: It should be inserted inside.
Alice: 集成电路还是什么
Alice: Integrated circuit or something?
Jake: 上一回我们一直在抱怨磁吸的问题
Jake: Last time we kept complaining about the magnetic issue.
Jake: 但是好像今天大家都没有什么
Jake: But it seems like today everyone's fine with it.
Lucia: 对今天大家好像接受良好
Jake: Yes, it seems like everyone's fine with it today.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Alice:：什么磁吸的
Alice: What magnetic?
Shure:  毕竟附赠的这个不可能给你
Shure: After all, the one that comes with it can't be given to you.
Lucia: 就是就是
Lucia: Exactly, exactly.
Lucia: 这个螺丝刀它没有磁吸
Lucia: This screwdriver doesn't have magnetic attraction.
Lucia: 对所以就是在这是装大的
Lucia: Right, so when installing screws, it's a hassle.
Lucia: 放螺丝的时候就很麻
Lucia: When placing the screws, it's a hassle.
Lucia: 对是这里是放大的
Lucia: Yes, this is for the larger ones.
Katrina:  嗯大的能卡进去
Katrina: Hmm, the big ones can snap in.
Lucia: 呃他就是这样子
Lucia: Uh, it's like this.
Lucia: 他没有办法就穿过这个孔
Lucia: It can't pass through this hole.
Lucia: 你就是要把
Lucia: You just need to...
Jake:你的头发总喜欢挡着镜头
Jake: Your hair always blocks the camera.
Jake: 要不想想办法
Jake: Maybe do something about it?
Jake: 对或者塞到里边去
Jake: Yeah, or tuck it inside.
Lucia: 大家是只要把它固定住就好
Lucia: As long as everyone can secure it, it's fine.
Lucia: 是是这样吗
Lucia: Is that right?
Jake: 嗯这个好
Jake: Hmm, this is good.
Shure:  我们
Shure: We...
Shure:  是不是可以有一点BGM
Shure: Shouldn't we have some background music?
Jake:让你放一点喂
Jake: Let you play a bit?
Lucia: 支持
Lucia: I support that.
Shure:  大家平时爱听什么类型的音乐
Shure: What type of music do you guys usually listen to?
Katrina:  我我听陶喆
Katrina: I, I listen to David Tao.
Jake: 陶喆类型的音乐
Jake: David Tao type music?
Jake: 嗯RMB RMB
Jake: Hmm, R&B, R&B.
Lucia: 混欧美圈的
Lucia: Mixed with Western music.
Lucia: 所以就乱听
Lucia: So I just listen to anything.
Alice: 给大家一个比较干劲的
Alice: Let's play something energetic for everyone.
Katrina:  好弹那个东北御姐的BGM
Katrina: Okay, play that Northeast Lady's BGM.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:来自东方
Jake: From the East.
Alice: 笑死我了，贼有劲
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 来跳吧要不然
Jake: Come on, let's dance, shall we?
Shure:  我想扛起来了
Shure: I feel like lifting it up.
扛起来
Shure: Lifting it up.
Shure:  呵呵呵这个半嵌入就行是吧
Shure: Haha, this half-embedded part should be fine, right?
Shure:  这样
Shure: Like this.
Jake: 对对古蔺游戏
Jake: Right, the ancient Lin game.
Alice:：ok了
Shure: 大东北 我的家乡
Shure: The great Northeast, my hometown.
Jake: 你东北哪的呀
Jake: Which part of Northeast are you from?
杨Shure: 我 稻花香
Shure: Daohuaxiang.
Jake: 东北稻花的
Jake: From Daohuaxiang in the Northeast.
Shure:  不是不是
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  那个长春的
Shure: From Changchun.
Jake: 长春的
Jake: From Changchun.
Shure: 吉林省长春市
Shure: Changchun, Jilin Province.
Shure:  大家知道这个城市吗
Shure: Does everyone know this city?
Katrina: 知道呀
Katrina: Yes, they do.
Shure:  大家知道吉林省还有个吉林市吗
Shure: Does everyone know there's also a city called Jilin in Jilin Province?
Alice:：啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake:对这也知道
Jake: Yes, we know that too.
Jake: 怎么你在吉林市
Jake: So, are you in Jilin city?
Jake: 没有我在吉林市
Jake: No, I'm in Jilin city.
Jake: 你们隔壁
Jake: You're next door.
Jake: 是吧好像是
Jake: Right? It seems like it.
Shure:  大东北
Shure: The northeast.
Shure:  AI人类为什么喜欢听这样的音乐
Shure: AI, why do humans like listening to this kind of music?
Lucia: 人类迷惑行为
Lucia: Human confusing behavior.
Jake: 然后这边有一个螺丝
Jake: And then there's a screw here.
Jake: 你看两边
Jake: Look, on both sides.
Lucia: 外面这好像不装回去也
Lucia: It seems like we don't need to put this back.
Lucia: 也可以就这个条
Lucia: It's okay, just this strip.
Lucia: 我们那天反正好像都扔了我记得
Lucia: I think we threw everything away that day anyway.
Jake: 我记得
Jake: I remember.
Shure:  这条刚好
Shure:  这条可以扔
Shure: This strip can be discarded.
Lucia: 这条可以可以任意摆
Lucia: This strip can be placed anywhere.
Jake: 我昨天成功的放了进去
Jake: I successfully put it in yesterday.
Lucia: 哦哦哦原来如此
Lucia: Oh, I see.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 那那那咱那天的嘞
Lucia: Then what about that day?
Jake: 没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Jake: 它就是美观
Jake: It's just for aesthetics.
Jake: 它就是看的没有螺丝
Jake: It's just so it looks like there are no screws.
Alice:：可以了吗
Jake: 然后把它这样
Jake: And then put it like this.
Shure: 可以进厂了
Shure: It can be placed.
Alice: 可以我已经进过厂了
Alice: Yes, I've been to the factory.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 啊你你进过厂玩过
Jake: Oh, you’ve been to the factory?
Alice: 我觉得我们大学那些接线的
Alice: I think our university wiring...
Alice: 焊板子的跟进厂没啥区别
Alice: Soldering boards isn't much different from going to the factory.
Jake: 物联网吗
Jake: The Internet of Things?
Jake: 还是什么
Jake: Or what?
Jake: 嗯电工
Jake: Hmm, electricians.
Alice: 对电工
Alice: Yes, electricians.
Lucia: 看吧对电工实习会做一些神奇的东西 我们学校也是
Lucia: See, electrician internships can create some amazing things. Our school too.
Jake: 最后最后放成这个样子
Jake: Finally, it ends up like this.
Jake: 好吧然后就就可以出叫出场了对
Jake: Okay, then we can wrap it up and call it a day, right?
Jake: 出流水线
Jake: Off the assembly line.
Jake: 下一个流水线
Jake: Next one on the assembly line.
Lucia: 下一个流水线是让你接到电脑上的
Lucia: The next one on the assembly line connects to the computer.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure:  下一个需要高级技工
Shure: The next one needs a senior technician.
Lucia: 哈哈哈高级技工
Lucia: Haha, senior technician.
Alice: 暂停吧吵吵的
Jake: 3,000的技工到5,000的技工
Jake: From a 3,000 technician to a 5,000 technician.
Shure:  你说的这是技工吗
Shure: Are you talking about a technician?
Alice: 什么是技工
Alice: What is Jigong?
Alice: 鸡公煲
Alice: Jigongbao, skilled worker.
Lucia: 技术工人
Shure:  哎为什么我
Shure: Hey, why me?
Alice: 因为你按反了啊
Alice: Because you pressed it the wrong way.
Jake: 这个是有俩螺丝啊
Jake: This has two screws.
Jake: 锁呢哎哎
Jake: The lock, hey, hey.
Shure:  完了太丢人了
Shure: It's over, so embarrassing.
Jake: 2,000的
Jake: 2,000.
Shure: 倒数第一了
Shure: Last place.
Jake:2,000了
Jake: 2,000.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 不行我必须要争一下
Shure: No, I have to fight for it.
Shure:  我不能倒数第一
Shure: I can't be last.
Shure:  哈哈好
Shure: Haha, okay.
Jake: 硬盘硬盘锦标赛
Jake: Hard drive, hard drive championship.
Katrina: 就不用干什么了吗
Lucia: 拧完应该就就好了
Lucia: It should be fine after you twist it.
Shure:  对他风轻云淡的说一句拧完了
Jake: Yeah, he casually said, "It's twisted."
Shure:  然后
Shure: Then...
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  他挑衅我
Shure: He's provoking me.
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Damn.
Jake:到底还有机会吗
Jake: Do I still have a chance?
Lucia: 是这样吗
Lucia: Is that so?
Lucia: 应该是吧
Lucia: Probably.
Jake: 对对对放到这个盒子里面
Jake: Yeah, yeah, put it in this box.
Shure:  你看你没有装上那一关
Jake: Look, you didn't pass that level.
Jake: 对条不用装这就是最后一步
Jake: Yeah, you don't need to put it there, this is the last step.
Jake: 给你一点机会但是你还是没有抓住
Jake: I gave you a chance, but you still didn't take it.
Katrina:  你可以把条放在里面
Jake: You can put the strip inside.
Lucia: 如果需要装的话
Lucia: If it needs to be installed.
Lucia: 然后尽量自己装就好了
Lucia: Then you should try to install it yourself.
Jake: 没需要装完全没必要放里面就好
Jake: No need to install it, just put it inside, it's totally fine.
Shure:  OK
Katrina: OK.
Shure:  他已经可以出场了出场
Shure: He can go on stage now.
Jake: 好谢谢大家
Jake: Alright, thank you, everyone.
Jake: 完成了一个奇怪的第一次任务
Jake: Completed a weird first mission.
Jake: 然后这个EGO life最后一天
Jake: And then, on the last day of EGO life.
Jake: 大家会邀请什么人呢
Jake: Who will everyone invite?
Shure:  啊最后一天
Shure: Ah, the last day.
Jake: 最后一天
Jake: The last day.
Shure: 是周日是吗
Shure: Is it Sunday?
Jake: 是周周日周日下午吧
Jake: It's Sunday, Sunday afternoon, right?
Shure:  啊咱俩会邀请什么人
Shure: Ah, who are we inviting?
Jake: 会邀请几个人
Jake: How many people are we inviting?
Jake: 呀
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 应该
Lucia: We should.
Shure: 黑板写一写吧
Shure: Let's write it on the board.
Jake: 对黑板可以写一写
Jake: Yeah, we can write it on the board.
Jake: 来我来我字非常好看
Jake: Let me do it, my handwriting is really nice.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 我们还有一个架子
Jake: We also have a rack.
Jake: 要不我们也拼一下好
Jake: How about we assemble it too?
Shure:  什么架子
Shure: What rack?
Shure:  就是不是
Shure: No, I mean...
Jake: 你如果觉得这个这么写很难写的话
Jake: If you find it hard to write like this...
Jake: 它其实有一个
Jake: Actually, there's...
Shure:  没有笔
Jake: No pen.
Jake: 就这个东西就是你可以假装再装吧
Jake: This thing, you can pretend to assemble it.
Shure:  行问题不大是吧
Shure: It's not a big deal, right?
Shure:  问题不大
Shure: It's not a big deal.
Jake:问题不大
Jake: It's not a big deal.
Shure:  不影响我这个书法的发挥
Shure: It won't affect my calligraphy.
Jake: 笔呢
Jake: Where's the pen?
Shure: 笔呢
Shure: Where's the pen?
Shure: 好问题
Shure: Good question.
Jake:好问题
Jake: Good question.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure:  问问他问问AI
Shure: Ask him, ask AI.
Shure:  笔呢
Shure: Where's the pen?
Jake:笔呢
Jake: Where's the pen?
Lucia: 寻找我的iPhone吗
Lucia: Find my iPhone?
Jake: 哈哈哈对笔呢
Jake: Hahaha, yeah, where's the pen?
Lucia: 寻找我的
Lucia: Looking for my
Lucia: 寻找我的pencil
Lucia: Looking for my pencil
Jake: 笔应该在上面
Jake: The pen should be up there.
Jake: 等一下啊
Jake: Wait a sec.
Shure:  我们都是iPhone
Shure: We all have iPhones.
Lucia: 好像应该是
Lucia: Seems like we do.
Alice: 我是ePhone
Alice: I'm an ePhone.
Shure:  咦什么烂梗啊哈哈哈
Shure: Eh, what a lame joke, hahaha.
Lucia: 啊这是个梗吗
Lucia: Ah, is that a joke?
Lucia: 我为什么没有改到iPhone
Lucia: Why didn't I change to an iPhone?
Katrina:  他是e人
Katrina: He's an ePerson.
Lucia: 哦哦OK
Lucia: Oh, oh, OK.
Lucia: 哎所以我们的e人到底是哪两位啊
Lucia: So who are our ePersons exactly?
Jake: 一
Jake: One.
Shure: 我我也是一
Shure: I'm one too.
Lucia: 哎你是一吗
Lucia: Hey, are you one?
Shure:  啊我我是E不是1啊OK
Shure: Ah, no, I'm E, not one, OK.
哈哈哈
Hahaha.
Jake:有啥差别啊
Jake: What's the difference?
Jake: 啊你是1哦
Jake: Ah, you're one.
Lucia: 所以哎那我们是6啊
Lucia: So we are 6.
Katrina:  算算一两
Katrina: Count, count, one, two.
Lucia: 哎那咱俩是然后呢
Lucia: So we are, and then?
Lucia: 啊OK昨天我没有
Lucia: Ah, OK, yesterday I didn't
Lucia: 昨天我没有猜出来
Lucia: Yesterday I didn't guess it.
Lucia: 虽然我猜到他可能是E人
Lucia: Though I guessed he might be an ePerson.
Shure: EGO life
Shure: EGO life.
Shure:  最后一天的名单行啊
Shure: The final day list, alright.
Jake:行啊
Shure:  拟
Shure:  邀
Jake:哈哈是这么写的
Jake: Haha, that's how you write it.
Jake: 笔画邀邀是这么写的
Shure:  是这么写的
Shure: It's written like this.
Shure:  嘉怎么写
Shure: How do you write "嘉"?
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 啊太久没写
Shure: Ah, it's been too long since I last wrote.
Tasha: 宝盖头
Tasha: The roof radical.
Katrina: 宝盖头
Katrina: The roof radical.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure:  OK第一位
Shure: OK, the first one.
Jake: 修硕你邀请几个人啊
Jake: Shure, how many people are you inviting?
Shure:  我浅浅邀一个吧
Shure: I'll just invite one for now.
Shure:  浅浅浅先邀一个啊
Shure: Just one for now.
Jake: 鲁亚呢
Jake: What about Luya?
Lucia: 我不太确定因为咱们这太远了
Lucia: I'm not sure because it's too far from here.
Lucia: 我不知道我小伙伴过不过得来
Lucia: I don't know if my friend can make it.
Jake: 好那你的工作室
Lucia: Well, then your studio.
Tasha: 我浅浅邀请一个吧
Tasha: I'll just invite one for now.
Jake: 好浅浅邀请一个
Jake: Okay, just invite one.
Shure:  叫什么名字
Shure: What's their name?
Jake: 用不着用不着
Jake: Doesn't matter.
Jake: 这就用不
Jake: Really doesn't.
Jake: 着了就是大概画个正字得了
Jake: Just draw a tally mark or something.
Shure:  啊画正字好
Shure: Ah, a tally mark is good.
Jake: 或者你用那个小球
Jake: Or you can use that little ball.
Jake: 我估计也够
Jake: I think that's enough.
Katrina:  画小人吧
Katrina: Just draw a little person.
Katrina:  男生就是这样
Katrina: Boys are like this.
Katrina:  女生夹两边
Katrina: Girls are like this with two sides.
Shure:  你邀请
Shure: You invite.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 这是你邀请的女生吗
Tasha: Is this the girl you invited?
Shure:  啊你啊
Tasha: 那我也邀请一位女生
Tasha: Then I'll invite a girl too.
Lucia: 你这个你这个辫
Lucia: This, this braid of yours.
Lucia: 他这个接口没有在头上
Lucia: This connector isn't on the top.
Alice:：抽象
Katrina:  这个假发
Katrina: This wig
Alice:：我的天啊。
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 我们冲天一下哎
Shure: Let's shoot up.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 我应该邀请一个男生
Katrina: I should invite a guy.
Shure:  男生
Shure: A guy.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Alice: 我爱心童的
Alice: I love children.
Katrina: 哈哈三条腿
Katrina: Haha, three legs.
Jake: 哈哈哈这合适吧这样
Jake: Hahaha, is this appropriate?
Alice:：哈哈哈哈
Shure:  对不起不小心画出头
Shure: Sorry, I accidentally drew a head.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Lucia: 我其实可以问一个女生
Lucia: I actually can ask a girl.
Lucia: 但我不确定她能不能过得来
Lucia: But I'm not sure if she can come.
Lucia: 因为她那边挺远的
Lucia: Because she's quite far away.
Lucia: 存疑是吧存疑
Lucia: Hahaha, doubtful, right, doubtful.
Alice:：哈哈哈
Jake: 还有你可以在每个人下面写一个名字
Jake: Also, you can write a name under each person.
Alice:：啊，我可以
Jake: 写一个他的host
Jake: Write their host.
Shure:  host是吗
Shure: Host, right?
Jake: 嗯就是你的代号嘛
Jake: Yeah, it's like your code name.
Shure:  嗯认领一下
Shure: Yeah, claim it.
Jake: 不不不
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake: 你就在这个小人的下面写一个
Jake: Just write one under the little person.
Jake: 或者在上面或者脸上写一个之类的
Jake: Or write it above or on the face or something.
Shure:  这是谁的来着那
Shure: Whose is this again then?
Alice: 啊塔莎
Alice: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 然后
Shure: And then
Alice:：这是宇轩的
Alice: This is Yuxuan's
Katrina:  嗯那写LX LYX
Katrina: Hmm, then write LX LYX
Jake: 啊哈哈哈哈
Jake: Ah hahaha
Alice:：哈哈哈好抽象
Shure:  这这位是谁的人
Shure: Whose person is this?
Lucia: 我录像或者写个l也行哈哈哈
Shure: I can record it or just write an "L" haha
Shure:  你要邀请奖了是吗
Shure: Ah, are you going for the invitation award?
Alice:：啊
Alice: 对但是有一个可能来不了
Alice: Yes, but one person might not make it
Shure:  性别
Shure: Gender
Alice:：都是女的
Alice: 有一个不知道能来不能
Tasha: There's one who might not be able to come
Alice: 你给我画个星就行了五角星
Tasha: Just draw me a star, a five-pointed star
Alice:：OK了
Shure:  现在我们有一二三四五六六位嘉宾
Shure: Now we have one, two, three, four, five, six guests
Jake: 嗯呃4-6位嘉宾
Jake: Hmm, uh, 4-6 guests
Shure:  对 4-6位
Shure: Yes, 4-6 guests
Jake:4-6位嘉宾OK
Jake: 4-6 guests, OK
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh
Jake: 我们原来还打算有可能的话
Jake: We originally planned, if possible
Jake: 去邀请周围的人
Jake: To invite people around us
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah
Jake:对
Jake: Right
Jake: 就是或者小红书
Jake: Or maybe from Xiaohongshu
Lucia: 还是
Lucia: Or
Lucia: 是采取挨家挨户敲门询问的方式吗
Lucia: Are you planning to go door-to-door asking?
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh
Jake:反正
Jake: Anyway
Tasha: 提一篮子鸡蛋比较好
Jake: Bringing a basket of eggs might be better
Jake: 环球影城门口直接抓人
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Lucia: 确实如果如
Lucia: Indeed, if
Lucia: 果就是如果他们来的话可以发鸡蛋
Lucia: If they come, we could give them eggs or something
Lucia: 听起来就像香肠一样
Lucia: Sounds like sausage or something
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Shure:  明天咱们这地就被举报了
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 明天可以拍一段警察的镜头哈哈哈
Jake: Tomorrow we could shoot a scene with the police, haha.
Shure:  2邀请邻居
Shure: Invite the neighbors.
Shure:  哎这邀字好难写
Shure: Ugh, this word "waist" is so hard to write.
Jake: 要不隐外字吧
Jake: How about skipping the word?
Shure:  我觉得也是
Shure: I think so too.
Shure:  带上系带
Shure: Tie it up.
Tasha: 你要是来我就把这一栏送你
Tasha: If you come, I'll give you this basket.
Tasha: 你不来就不送
Tasha: If you don't come, I won't give it.
Tasha: 哈哈隐
Tasha: Haha, hide.
Shure:  邻居
Shure:  哎这字
Shure: Ugh, this word.
Shure:  齐白石看着都落泪
Shure: Even Qi Baishi would cry looking at this.
Alice: 有种复古的感觉
Alice: It has a vintage feel.
Shure:  这是我们的plan
Shure: This is our plan.
Shure:  存疑plan
Shure: A questionable plan.
Shure:  okay
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 好多问号啊
Lucia: So many question marks.
Lucia: 我们好像谜语人
Lucia: We seem like riddlers.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: the riddle
Shure: The riddle.
Shure:  然后我们还还有
Shure: And then we still have...
Shure:  还有什么
Shure: What else do we have?
Jake: 呃这是人员
Jake: Uh, this is the personnel.
Shure:  不对
Shure: No.
Jake: 呃剧组吧剧组还有5个人
Jake: Uh, the crew, the crew still has 5 people.
Jake: 然后对总共看
Jake: And then, overall...
Jake: 最后我们要host多少个人
Jake: Finally, how many people do we need to host?
Jake: 然后看看这活动在这个人数下
Jake: And then let's see how this event goes with this number of people.
Jake: 应该整点啥
Jake: What should we do?
Alice:：绞丝
Jake: 给大家拍
Jake: Filming it for everyone.
Jake: 这可以技术处理一下吗
Jake: Can we edit this technically?
Jake: 是但是
Jake: Yes, but...
Shure: 后期给
Shure: For post-production.
Jake:后期很麻烦哈哈
Jake: It's a hassle for post-production, haha.
Shure:  添了多少麻烦
Shure: How much of a hassle?
Shure:  OK所以总共one two three four
Shure: OK, so in total, one, two, three, four.
Alice: 4到6 个
Shure: four加五五个
Shure: Four plus five, five.
Shure:  这是9
Shure: That's 9.
Jake:4加五九
Jake: Four plus five, nine.
Jake: 九九九到11是吧
Jake: Nine, nine, nine to 11, right?
Shure:  9到11 人
Shure: 9 to 11 people.
Jake: 9到11 然后各位自己
Jake: 9 to 11, then everyone can...
Shure:  算算上我们是吧
Shure: Including us, right?
Jake:可以 哎就先先先就写到9-11吧
Jake: Okay, let's just note it down as 9-11 for now.
Jake: 9-11
Jake: 9-11.
Shure: 9-11 徒正无穷
Shure: 9-11, it's endless.
Shure:  因为我们可以邀请邻居
Shure: Because we can invite neighbors.
Jake: 嗯对对
Jake: Yeah, right, right.
Jake: 非常也有无穷的邻居
Jake: There's also endless neighbors.
Jake: 也不是正无穷吧 16亿
Jake: Not really endless, 1.6 billion.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:：太严谨了
Shure:  现在我们我我国人有16亿了吗
Shure: Do we have 1.6 billion people now?
Jake: 14
Jake: 1.4.
Shure: 14吧
Shure: 1.4 then.
Jake:那就14
Jake: Then it's 14.
Shure:  完了这移动的
Shure: Oh no, it's moving.
Jake:报数多了
Jake: Too many counts.
Jake: 哈哈合适吗
Jake: Haha, is that appropriate?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Jake: 问题不大问题不大
Jake: It's not a big problem, not a big problem.
Shure:  一OK
Shure: One OK.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Shure:  然后好人员确定了
Shure: And then, personnel is confirmed.
Shure:  嗯这是第一
Shure: Hmm, this is the first...
Shure:  第一大点的第三
Shure: First big point's third...
Shure:  下面三个小点人员
Shure: Next, three small points of personnel.
Shure:  然后我们还有第二点
Shure: And then we have the second point.
Shure:  要开始活
Shure: To start working...
Shure:  动内容部分吗
Shure: On the content part?
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Shure:  这我觉得是一块硬骨头我们要啃很久
Shure: I think this is a tough nut to crack, we'll be at it for a while.
Shure:  嗯所以我们要直接先来这个吗
Shure: Hmm, so should we start with this directly?
Jake: 那还有别的吗
Jake: Is there anything else?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  活动内容
Shure: Activity content.
Shure:  大家想想
Shure: Everyone think about it.
Shure:  我记得大家问卷的时候应该是填过的
Shure: I remember everyone filled out the questionnaire, right?
Shure:  嗯是吧
Shure: Hmm, right?
Jake: 是的
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 大家问卷填的是什么来着
Shure: What did everyone fill in the questionnaire again?
Shure:  不会都是GPT生成的吧
Shure: It wasn't all generated by GPT, was it?
Shure:  不是哈哈哈
Katrina: No, hahaha, I wrote it myself.
Jake: 湖南GPT生成的
Jake: I wrote it myself, generated by Hunan GPT.
Shure:  那既然提到湖南GPT那我们先从
Shure:  Lyx同学
Shure: Lyx student.
Katrina:  哈哈哈我我想是那个就是呃7天
Katrina: I think it's like, um, 7 days.
Katrina:  然后每我买那花嘛
Katrina: And then I buy the flowers.
Katrina:  然后每人一个花瓶
Katrina: And then each person gets a vase.
Katrina:  然后就相当于醒花一一到2天
Katrina: Then you let the flowers wake up for 1 to 2 days.
Katrina:  然后刚好他一个周期
Katrina: And it's just right for one cycle.
Katrina:  就是可以让这花慢慢的开放
Katrina: So the flowers can slowly bloom.
Katrina:  然后把这个花的花瓣
Katrina: Then you take the petals.
Katrina:  然后做成那种压花
Katrina: And make pressed flowers.
Katrina:  然后就比较环保做成那种明信片
Katrina: It's more eco-friendly to make postcards this way.
Katrina:  还有买了那种亚克力的玻璃
Katrina: I also bought some acrylic glass.
Katrina:  然后就嵌进去
Katrina: And then embed it.
Katrina:  就是那种比较好看的手工
Katrina: It's a pretty handicraft.
Katrina:  然后也跟植物有关
Katrina: And it's related to plants.
Katrina:  然后原材料又是自己精心养了7天的
Katrina: The raw materials are carefully grown by myself for 7 days.
Katrina:  然后又觉得形成了一个闭环
Katrina: And I feel like it forms a closed loop.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Katrina: 就做了一些周边
Katrina: So we made some peripherals.
Katrina:  到时候那一天就可以分发给大家
Katrina: And we can distribute them to everyone that day.
Jake: 上才艺
Jake: Show your talents.
Katrina:  那花的在哪
Katrina: Where are the flowers?
Katrina:  花还要醒一的
Katrina: The flowers need to wake up.
Katrina:  因为我看我
Katrina: Because I...
Katrina:  我刚才想的是种那种什么东西
Katrina: I was just thinking about what to plant.
Katrina:  符合那种地球世界
Katrina: Something that fits the Earth Day theme.
Katrina:  地球日他7天基本上发不了芽
Katrina: But for Earth Day, 7 days is not enough for seeds to sprout.
Katrina:  然后我就想是买这种花
Katrina: So I thought of buying these flowers.
Jake:上才艺
Jake: Show talent.
Katrina: : 直接那个顺丰发过来
Jake:是这个吗
Jake: Is this it?
Katrina:  云南的花
Katrina: Flowers from Yunnan.
Lucia: 是他好像有两个苞
Lucia: It looks like it has two buds.
Katrina:  对我买了芍药啊
Katrina: Yeah, I bought peonies.
Jake:不想送了
Jake: You don't want to give them away anymore?
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina:  刚好一些花骨朵就这两天就可以开了
Katrina: Some flower buds will bloom in the next few days.
Lucia: 你要找个剪刀什么的吗
Lucia: Do you need to find some scissors or something?
Alice: 剪刀昨天
Katrina:  JK Gan吗还是说要把后面的列完
Katrina: JK Gan or should we just list out the ones at the back?
Jake: 呃先秀一下
Jake: Uh, show them first.
Shure: 先秀一下
Shure: Show them first.
Jake:先秀一下
Jake: Show them first.
Alice:：剪刀不在那
Alice: The scissors are missing.
Katrina:  我买了好几束来着
Katrina: I bought several bunches.
Shure: 剪刀在这儿呢
Shure: The scissors are here.
Katrina: 还买了康乃馨
Katrina: I also bought some carnations.
Katrina:  哈哈
Alice: Thank you.
Alice: 谢谢
Jake: 眼神好啊小伙
Jake: Good eyesight, kid.
Alice:：我来吧
Katrina:  刚好我们女孩子比较多哈哈
Alice: It’s just that we have more girls here, haha.
Alice:：给
Katrina:  啊这也是
Katrina: Ah, that too.
Katrina:  这花瓣就可以做压花
Katrina: These petals can be used for pressed flowers.
Katrina:  然后买了压花器还有那种干燥剂
Katrina: So, I bought a flower press and some desiccant.
Katrina:  这是什么
Lucia: What is this?
Katrina:  这是花这个要晾一下
Katrina: This is a flower, it needs to be aired out.
Alice: 这是芍药吗
Tasha: Is it a peony?
Katrina:  嗯我买多了我才知道
Alice: Yeah, I bought too many, then I realized.
Katrina:  他说要一到两天才能开花
Katrina: They said it would take one to two days to bloom.
Katrina:  然后想时间就差不多
Katrina: So, the timing is just right.
Katrina:  压花就要压个两三天
Katrina: Pressing flowers takes about two or three days.
Katrina:  压花就要压两三天
Katrina:  然后这个养个两三天
Katrina: Then this takes about two or three days to nurture.
Alice:：这是什么百合
Alice:：香雪蓝还是啥
Alice: Freesia or something?
Alice: 林兰百合蓝
Katrina: What kind of lily was it again? Lily blue?
Alice: 这两个颜色的
Alice: These two colors.
Katrina:  对一个白一个黄
Katrina: Yeah, one is white and one is yellow.
Katrina:  是一个包裹
Katrina: It's in one package.
Katrina:  我看我记得他好像发两个包裹
Katrina: I remember he sent two packages.
Jake: 要不他上我们也上
Jake: How about if he goes up, we go up too?
Jake: 才艺你看看哪些是你的
Jake: Talents, see which ones are yours.
Tasha: 没有我的
Tasha: None are mine.
Jake: 没有你的啊
Jake: None are yours?
Jake: 你没有买这个
Jake: You didn't buy this?
Jake: 还有别人买快递
Jake: Did anyone else buy deliveries?
Lucia: 你们买东西了吗
Lucia: Did you guys buy anything?
Shure:  还没呢还没
Shure: Not yet, not yet.
Jake: 行没问题
Jake: Okay, no problem.
Alice:：康乃馨
Jake: 他们都是自带的是吧
Jake: He brushes everything himself, right?
Shure:  带资进组
Shure: He brought his own funds into the group.
Shure:  你看这就
Shure: Look, this is...
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
老板：觉悟
Jake: Enlightenment.
Katrina:  然后呢然后就花瓶你比划一比划
Katrina: Then, then you compare the vase.
Jake: 比划比划
Jake: Compare it.
Jake: 就是大概要个什么形式
Jake: Like, what kind of style do you want?
Katrina: 形式吗 形式就是我们6个人一人一个花瓶
Katrina: Style? The style is, we six people each have a vase.
Katrina:  花瓶我也买好了
Katrina: I also bought the vases.
Katrina:  然后大家把这花分分分分了以后养了
Katrina: Then everyone divides the flowers and nurtures them.
Katrina:  一一一到两三天
Katrina: One to two or three days.
Katrina:  呃他这个就会慢慢全部开了吗
Katrina: Uh, will this slowly open up completely?
Katrina:  开了以后就用这种花瓣或者是
Katrina: After it opens, we can use these petals or
Katrina:  我看他们压花
Katrina: I saw them pressing flowers
Katrina:  就是直接把这个花骨朵花剪下来
Katrina: They just cut the flower bud directly
Katrina:  然后就直接这样压
Katrina: And then press it like this
Katrina:  他就会变成一个那种平面的
Katrina: It will become a flat, open flower
Katrina:  然后展开的那个花
Katrina: Then you can put it on a postcard
Katrina:  然后就可以坐在那种明信片
Katrina: The kind of postcard I bought
Katrina:  我买的那种明信片贺卡
Katrina: And those, what's it called
Katrina:  还有那个包括那个叫什么
Katrina: Those acrylic double-layer glass
Katrina:  那种亚克力双层玻璃
Katrina: Like a photo frame, you can
Katrina:  然后像像一个那种相框就可以
Katrina: Give it to someone, with some leaves and stuff
Katrina:  送给别人然后一些叶子啊什么的
Katrina: At the time, I was thinking
Katrina:  然后当时想的是
Katrina: Since you have outdoor activities
Katrina:  你不是有那个户外活动吗
Katrina: We can pick up some leaves
Katrina:  我们就可以去捡一些叶子
Katrina: And put them together like a painting
Katrina:  然后就把它拼成一幅画一样的
Katrina: Yeah
Katrina:  对
Katrina: And also bookmarks, everyone can make their own
Katrina:  然后书签也有然后就大家自己做着玩
Katrina: And on the last day
Katrina:  然后最后一天
Katrina: Because I was thinking of this format
Katrina:  因为想这种形式
Katrina: We can invite friends and stuff
Katrina:  这种就邀请什么各种好朋友啊什么的
Katrina: You can give out what you made and grew yourself
Katrina:  就可以你自己做的自己养的
Katrina: It's quite nice and fits the 7-day cycle
Katrina:  然后分发给大家就挺好
Katrina: It's really nice
Katrina:  然后也比较符合7天这个周期嘛
Katrina: And it fits the 7-day cycle
Alice: 嗯要不先给他醒了吧
Alice: Hmm, should we wake him up first?
Katrina:  嗯可以啊今天我肯今天是一定要
Katrina: Hmm, sure, I think today we definitely should
Jake: 先聊吧这个回头下一个
Jake: Let's chat first, and then the next one
Katrina:  行下一个下一个谁
Katrina: Alright, who's next?
Alice: 下一个
Tasha: Next one
Katrina: 我来弄这个
Katrina: I'll do this one
Shure: 下一个 路路亚同学啊
Shure: Next one, Lulua
Katrina:  我
Katrina: I
Shure: 露西
Shure: Lucia
Lucia: 啊其实就是我的构思
Lucia: Ah, actually, this is my idea.
Lucia: 也跟DIY是有关系的
Lucia: It's also related to DIY.
Lucia: 对我刚我刚开始想的是
Lucia: So at first, I was thinking
Lucia: 就是可以因为是世界地球日
Lucia: Since it's Earth Day,
Lucia: 所以我想就是做一点环保一点的东西
Lucia: I wanted to do something a bit more eco-friendly.
Lucia: 就我不知道大家有没有做过水母灯
Lucia: I don't know if any of you have made jellyfish lamps before.
Lucia: 就这两年在景区还挺火的
Lucia: They've been quite popular at scenic spots these past two years.
Lucia: 呃就是长得像水母一样的一个小灯
Lucia: Um, it's a small lamp that looks like a jellyfish.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 然后这个东西它原本是有材料包的
Lucia: So, originally, you could buy a kit online.
Lucia: 就是可以直接在网上买材料包做
Lucia: You could get a kit and make it yourself.
Lucia: 但是我就是我想的是
Lucia: But what I was thinking is,
Lucia: 就是既然是世界地球日的话
Lucia: Since it's Earth Day,
Lucia: 我之前在网上刷到过一个教程
Lucia: I saw a tutorial online before,
Lucia: 就是可以用那个奶茶杯盖
Lucia: That you could use a bubble tea cup lid
Lucia: 然后以它作为一个主体
Lucia: And use that as the main body.
Lucia: 然后就是再加一些丝带
Lucia: Then add some ribbons
Lucia: 或者串珠之类的
Lucia: Or beads and such.
Lucia: 呃我不知道咱们这有没有热热胶枪
Lucia: Um, I don't know if we have a hot glue gun.
Lucia: 如果没有的话
Lucia: If not,
Lucia: 可以后面看有没有什么替代的
Lucia: We can see if there's an alternative,
Lucia: 或者说买一个也行
Lucia: Or we can buy one.
Lucia: 然后就是大家一起
Lucia: Then everyone can
Lucia: 就是每个人都做一个这样的小灯
Lucia: Make a small lamp together.
Lucia: 就是它还挺好看的
Lucia: It looks really nice.
Lucia: 然后这是其中一个设想
Lucia: And that's one idea.
Lucia: 还有一个就是也是
Lucia: Another idea is also
Lucia: 有点这种怎么说呢
Lucia: Sort of like,
Lucia: 低碳和循环利用的
Lucia: Low-carbon and recycling.
Lucia: 就是大家有没有做过纸箱小狗
Lucia: Have you ever made cardboard dogs?
Lucia: 就前段时间特别火那个啊
Lucia: They were really popular recently.
Katrina:  可以放在那个
Katrina: You can put it at the
Lucia: 对然后可以放在门口
Lucia: Yeah, you can put it at the door.
Lucia: 然后纸箱小狗的好处就是
Lucia: And the good thing about cardboard dogs is,
Lucia: 如果想要很简单做一下的话
Lucia: If you want to make it simple,
Lucia: 就拿纸箱简单剪一下
Lucia: Just cut the cardboard box simply.
Lucia: 然后画一个小狗头粘上就可以
Lucia: Then draw a small dog's head and stick it on.
Lucia: 如果想要复杂一点的话
Lucia: If you want it to be more complex,
Lucia: 就是也有一些
Lucia: you can also
Lucia: 就是复杂点就需要多剪几个
Lucia: you know, make it more complex by cutting out more pieces.
Lucia: 然后做成一个大的
Lucia: Then make a big one.
Lucia: 我之前看到有人做过杜宾
Lucia: I once saw someone make a Doberman.
Lucia: 但是那个我没做过就是
Lucia: But I haven't done that myself.
Lucia: 但是就是看了一下教程
Lucia: I just looked at the tutorial.
Lucia: 好像也挺简单的
Lucia: It seems pretty easy.
Lucia: 只要画一下卡纸就能很容易剪出来
Lucia: You just need to draw on the cardboard and cut it out easily.
Shure:  咱们最不缺的就是纸箱
Shure: We have plenty of cardboard boxes.
Shure:  所以我觉得这个
Lucia: 对我当时想的也是
Lucia: That's what I thought too.
Lucia: 在咱们这里到时候肯定会有很多纸箱
Lucia: We will definitely have a lot of cardboard boxes here.
Lucia: 如果说就能直接使用的话
Lucia: So if we can just use them directly...
Lucia: 就还挺环保的
Lucia: 就也很契合世界地球日这个主题
Lucia: It really fits the Earth Day theme too.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: start
Shure: Start.
Lucia: 然后最后还有一个想法
Lucia: And there's one more idea I have.
Lucia: 但是这个想法实施起来就比较困难
Lucia: But it's a bit difficult to implement.
Lucia: 我本来想的是
Lucia: What I was thinking is...
Lucia: 可能大家可以简单的排一个小短剧
Lucia: Maybe we could put together a short skit.
Lucia: 或者之类的
Lucia: Or something like that.
Lucia: 对因为我之前跟我小伙伴有说
Lucia: Because I talked to my friends about it before.
Lucia: 我们今天拍一些微电影这种
Lucia: We were thinking of shooting some short films today.
Lucia: 但是如果要排一个小短剧的话
Lucia: But if we want to do a short skit...
Lucia: 就是我现在暂时还没有想到一个现成
Lucia: I don't have a ready-made script in mind right now.
Lucia: 我们目前就拿来用的剧本
Lucia: Because we're short on time.
Lucia: 因为咱们时间比较短
Lucia: If we try to write one now...
Lucia: 就如果要现在去编的话
Lucia: It might be too rushed.
Lucia: 可能就不太来得及
Lucia: So if anyone has any ideas...
Lucia: 就如果大家有想到什么
Lucia: Like any short videos you've seen before...
Lucia: 你们以前看到过的短视频之类的
Lucia: That could work too.
Lucia: 这种也可以
Lucia: 就如果有个现成的剧本
Lucia: If we have a ready-made script
Lucia: 我觉得咱们可以尝试拍一下
Lucia: I think we can try to shoot it
Shure:  对OK
Shure: Right, OK
Lucia: 好这个是目前暂时的想法
Lucia: Alright, this is our current idea
Shure:  这是Lucia
Shure: This is Lucia
Shure:  这是
Shure: This is
Shure:  露西亚哈哈
Shure: Lucia, haha
Lucia: 哦我们两个名字好像
Lucia: Oh, our names sound so similar
Alice: 你把他名写反了哎
Alice: You wrote his name backwards
Lucia: 刘Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Liu Alice, hahaha
Alice: 加一道就行
Alice: Just add one more
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Alice:：哈哈哈
Katrina:  完了就是那个变异来磕完染色体的
Katrina: And then the mutation came to finish off the chromosomes
Jake: 对对对变异
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, mutation
Shure:  好家伙这俩你都有
Shure: Wow, you have both of these
Shure:  是吗哈哈哈哈
Shure: Really? Hahaha
Shure:  TASHA
Tasha: OK上我的道具拿出来哈哈哈哈
Tasha: OK, bring out my props, hahaha
Jake: 上道具BGM
Jake: Bring out the props BGM
Shure:  当当当当当当当
Shure: Dun dun dun dun dun
Tasha: 当当当
Tasha: Dun dun dun
Lucia: 说明有背景音乐哈哈
Lucia: Meaning there's background music, haha
Shure:  他的道具为什么在你的行李箱里
Shure: Why are his props in your suitcase
Jake: 啊因为又是代言人
Jake: Ah, because he's the spokesperson again
Tasha: 不就这个
Tasha: Isn't it just this one
Tasha: 就这个啊
Tasha: Just this one
Tasha: 你怎么没拆
Tasha: Why didn't you unpack it
Tasha: 我去拿个现成的吧
Tasha: I'll go get a ready-made one.
Tasha: 你把培养皿拿出来吧
Tasha: You take out the petri dish.
Shure:  培养皿
Shure: Petri dish.
Jake:培养皿
Jake: Petri dish.
Jake: 培养皿买了
Jake: Bought the petri dish.
Jake: 但是不一定到了
Jake: But it might not have arrived yet.
Jake: 不一定到哈
Jake: It might not be here yet.
Jake: 我看一下
Jake: Let me check.
Katrina:  买了康乃馨
Katrina: Bought some carnations.
Katrina:  这个叫叫叫
Katrina: This is called, called, called...
Katrina:  芍药康乃馨
Katrina: Peony carnations.
Katrina:  直播间买的
Katrina: Bought it from a live stream.
Lucia: 哈哈好好看呀
Katrina: Haha, it looks so good.
Lucia: 直播间买
Lucia: Bought it from a live stream.
Katrina:  顺丰秒送
Lucia: SF Express delivery.
Katrina:  哎他昨天花瓶昨天也到了
Katrina: Hey, his vase arrived yesterday too.
Jake: 对到了
Jake: Yeah, it did.
Katrina:  这都是我们的快递
Katrina: These are all our deliveries.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Tasha: 好像没有别的种类
Tasha: Seems like there are no other types.
Katrina:  可以装在这种里面
Katrina: You can put it inside this.
Katrina:  我看一下
Katrina: Let me check.
Katrina:  弄出来特别漂亮
Katrina: It looks really nice.
Shure:  你这是香
Shure: Is that an incense holder?
Katrina:  对就把花夹在里面
Katrina: Yeah, just clip the flowers inside.
Katrina:  还有一些叶子什么的可以摆在家里
Katrina: And you can put some leaves and stuff, looks great at home.
Katrina:  这确实这怎么雾蒙蒙的
Katrina: This really looks kind of foggy.
Katrina:  他中间应该夹了一层东西
Katrina: There must be a layer of something in the middle.
Jake: 被嫌弃了
Jake: It's being disliked.
Jake: 我应该拆吗
Jake: Should I unpack it?
Tasha: 然后哈哈
Tasha: And then haha.
Tasha: 就是这是
Tasha: So this is...
Tasha: 自己设计的一些种子纸
Tasha: Some seed paper that I designed.
Tasha: 就是把种子放在这个纸里面
Tasha: You just put the seeds inside this paper.
Tasha: 这个纸是用废弃的咖啡渣
Tasha: This paper is made from used coffee grounds.
Tasha: 呃一些纸
Tasha: Uh, some paper.
Tasha: 然后做成那种纸浆
Tasha: Then it's turned into pulp.
Tasha: 然后纸浆里面有那种乳种子
Tasha: And the pulp has seeds in it.
Tasha: 都是用的太阳花种子
Tasha: They use sunflower seeds.
Tasha: 太阳花种子它比较容易发芽
Tasha: Sunflower seeds are easier to sprout.
Tasha: 然后如果用培养皿水培的话
Tasha: And if you use petri dishes and water culture,
Tasha: 大概5天左右就可以发芽
Tasha: They can sprout in about 5 days.
Tasha: 然后做了一些种类的
Tasha: And I made a few varieties.
Tasha: 算世界地球日吗
Tasha: Does this count as Earth Day?
Jake: 那可地球了
Jake: Totally for Earth.
Alice: 这是你自己做的吗
Jake: Did you make this yourself?
Lucia: 好厉害
Katrina: So impressive, yeah.
Tasha: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina:  好厉害
Katrina: So impressive.
Tasha: 然后做了5种
Tasha: And I made five kinds.
Tasha: 地球的
Tasha: For the Earth.
Tasha: 然后做了两种很简单的
Tasha: And then two simple ones.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 但是你是原创哎
Lucia: But it's your original creation.
Jake: 有点强
Jake: Pretty strong.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake: 种子片
Jake: Seed paper.
Jake: 种子片嗯
Jake: Seed paper, yeah.
Shure:  种子片
Shure: Seed paper.
Jake:种子片
Jake: Seed paper.
Tasha: 嗯然后这样就比较环保
Tasha: Yeah, this way it's more eco-friendly.
Lucia: 嗯真的很环保
Katrina: Yeah, it's really eco-friendly.
Lucia: 真的很环保
Lucia: Really eco-friendly.
Katrina:  而且还极具美感好吗
Katrina: And it's also aesthetically pleasing.
Katrina:  1234 好
Katrina: 1234, alright.
Jake: 那你自己设计的
Jake: Did you design this yourself?
Alice:：噢对，我得去拿下我的东西
Jake: 是画的图吗
Jake: Is it the drawing?
Tasha: 啊这很简单了
Tasha: Ah, this is very simple.
Tasha: 就找一些logo
Tasha: Just find some logos.
Tasha: 然后这个logo一找
Tasha: Then once you find the logo,
Tasha: 写个字框个框就行了
Tasha: write some text and put it in a box, that's it.
Tasha: OK
Tasha: OK.
Jake: 挺好的挺好
Jake: That's great, really good.
Lucia: 好厉害
Lucia: Awesome.
Katrina:  种子卡片
Katrina: Seed cards.
Katrina:  然后呢就是
Katrina: And then it's like...
Alice: 嗯买了一个拼图
Alice: Hmm, I bought a puzzle.
Alice: 是一个呃大底层是一个圆的
Alice: It's a, uh, the base layer is round.
Alice: 然后它那个里面是这种的
Alice: And inside it's like this.
Alice: 就是各种动物的那种
Alice: It's all kinds of animals.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:：然后你看你能不能
Alice: Then you see if you can...
Alice: 就是一个比较难的一个拼图
Alice: It's a relatively difficult puzzle.
Alice: 然后有很多种动物
Alice: And it has many kinds of animals.
Alice: 我想的就是呃你去尽力的往里面拼
Alice: I was thinking, uh, you try to fit them in.
Alice: 就是我觉得这个拼图就给人一种
Alice: I think this puzzle gives a feeling like
Alice: 我们在地球上
Alice: we're on Earth,
Alice: 可以和谐共处的那个感觉
Alice: and we can coexist harmoniously.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice: 然后你不一定全都能拼上
Alice: And you might not be able to fit everything.
Alice: 但是因为这种不是那个严丝合缝
Alice: Because it's not a perfect fit.
Alice: 不是特别完全严丝合缝
Alice: It's not perfectly seamless.
Alice: 就是说你可以拼多一点
Alice: So you can fit more pieces,
Alice: 也可以拼少一点
Alice: or you can fit fewer pieces.
Alice: 然后我就想
Alice: And I was thinking,
Alice: 呃可能就是一个小的游戏吧
Alice: uh, maybe it's just a small game.
Jake: 头头发
Jake: Hair, hair.
Jake: 呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Alice:：对
Alice: Right.
Jake:要不
Jake: How about...
Jake: 要不夹进去
Jake: How about we clip it in
Lucia: 有没有夹子
Lucia: Do we have a clip?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Alice: 然后就是
Shure: And then
Alice: 我就想给参与者就是一个小奖品
Alice: I just want to give the participants a little prize
Alice: 就是一颗水仙种球
Alice: It's a daffodil bulb
Alice: 因为这个水仙种球它好养
Alice: Because this daffodil bulb is easy to grow
Alice: 就是呃
Alice: Like, um
Alice: 在我的那种植物杀手朋友身上
Alice: I've tried it with my friends who are plant killers
Alice: 试验过了
Alice: And they managed to keep it alive
Alice: 他都能养活的东西
Alice: They can keep it alive
Alice: 然后这个花开出来也特别的好看
Alice: And the flowers that bloom are really pretty
Alice: 然后还有清香的味道
Alice: And they have a nice fragrance
Alice: 并且你看着他一天天长大
Alice: And you can watch it grow day by day
Alice: 你很有那种参与自然的感觉
Alice: You get this feeling of participating in nature
Alice: 对所以这就是我的想法
Alice: So yeah, that's my idea
Alice: 但是水仙球还没买
Alice: But I haven't bought the daffodil bulbs yet
Alice: 但是我有
Alice: But I have
Alice: 我知道有一家质量特别好的
Alice: I know a place with really good quality ones
Alice: 我养过的就是
Alice: I've grown them before
Alice: 有需要他可以直接买过来
Alice: If needed, we can just buy them
Jake: 好
Alice: Okay
Jake: 仙球
Jake: Daffodil bulbs
Shure:  活动内容现在有4个
Shure: There are four activities now
Shure:  到谁了
Shure: Whose turn is it?
Alice: 我写吧
Alice: 不是到我了吗
Shure:  野生动物拼图
Shure: Wildlife puzzle
Katrina:  哎我还想让我第一天吃海底捞
Katrina: Hey, I still want my first day at Haidilao
Katrina:  送了我一个种草莓的那个盆栽
Katrina: They gave me a strawberry planting pot
Katrina:  也可以种一下
Katrina: You can also plant something
Jake:海底捞
Jake: Haidilao
Tasha: 那那个豌豆还可以种
Tasha: And those peas can be planted too
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yes
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Katrina:  海底捞就最近不是跟樱桃小丸子联名
Katrina: Hai Di Lao recently collaborated with Chibi Maruko-chan
Katrina:  点他那个东西他就送你那个盆栽
Katrina: If you order that thing, they give you a potted plant
Katrina:  哦这么好
Katrina: Oh, that's so nice
Shure:  嗯我草莓宿舍摆
Lucia: Hmm, I'll put it in my strawberry dorm
Katrina:  我说他咋知道我要过来种东西
Katrina: I was wondering how they knew I wanted to plant something
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina:  我当时本来想买盆栽来着
Katrina: I actually wanted to buy a potted plant at the time
Katrina:  想盆栽要一个月才能发芽
Katrina: I thought it would take a month for the plant to sprout
Jake: 走上海边种树去
Jake: Let's go plant trees by the sea
Shure:  然后到我了
Shure: And then it was my turn
Jake:到您了
Jake: Your turn
Shure:  我的是一个啧
Shure: Mine is a...
Shure:  一个类似于二手拍卖的
Shure: A kind of second-hand auction
Shure:  一个一个一个一个一个一个一个想法
Shure: A, a, a, a, a, a, a, an idea
Jake: OK
Shure: 我不知道
Shure: I don't know
Shure:  大家平时会不会去一些什么
Shure: Does anyone usually go to places like
Shure:  比如说小小小酒馆啊
Shure: For example, small bars
Shure:  或者是咖啡店
Shure: Or coffee shops
Shure:  就那种比较有烟火气的地方
Shure: Those places with a lot of local life
Shure:  然后之前那个
Shure: And previously
Shure:  北京有一个连锁的精酿啤酒
Shure: There was a chain craft beer place in Beijing
Shure:  叫跳海
Shure: Called Tiao Hai
Katrina: 哦我知道在什刹海那是不是
Katrina: Oh, I know, it's in Shichahai, right?
Shure:  对什刹海应该是这个吧
Shure: Yes, Shichahai, I think it's this one
Jake: 然后指的是这个吗
Jake: And it's referring to this one?
Shure:  其其他城市也有
Shure: Other cities also have it
Shure:  什么市场也有
Shure: Some markets also have it
Shure:  然后他们前两天大榕寺开业的时候
Shure: And a few days ago when Dazhong Temple opened
Shure:  他们搞了一个
Shure: They did a...
Shure:  就是类似于这个拍卖的
Shure: Like an auction
Shure:  一个一个一个形式吧
Shure: One by one, in a certain way.
Shure:  然后就是
Shure: And then...
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Um...
Shure:  他们当时是你喝酒会给你一个币
Shure: Back then, when you drank, they would give you a coin.
Jake: 知道吗
Jake: You know?
Shure: 然后用这个币
Shure: Then use the coin...
Shure:  来买大家的一些任何的东西
Shure: To buy anything from everyone.
Shure:  可以是一个是是一个诗集
Shure: It could be a collection of poems...
Shure:  可以是一个故事
Shure: Or a story...
Shure:  然后也可以是一个
Shure: Or even...
Shure:  就是真实存在的一个物品
Shure: A real, tangible item.
Shure:  然后就每人
Shure: Then each person...
Shure:  就是那个每个物品都做一个小的PPT
Shure: Would make a small PPT for each item...
Shure:  然后展示出来
Shure: And present it.
Katrina: 啊还要做ppt吗
Katrina: Ah, we have to make a PPT?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha...
Lucia: 这是工作狂游戏吗
Lucia: Is this a workaholic game?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha...
Shure:  啊不然后然
Lucia: Hahaha, oh no, then...
Shure:  后然后
Shure: Then...
Shure:  然后然后
Shure: Then, then...
Shure:  然后就是一个拍卖吧
Shure: Then we have an auction.
Shure:  然后我们可以怎么样呢
Shure: And we can, um...
Shure:  就是来的这些嘉宾
Shure: The guests who come...
Shure:  然后大家一人分享一个故事
Shure: Each share a story...
Shure:  或者是呃
Shure: Or, uh...
Shure:  事故也好
Shure: An incident...
Shure:  故事也好
Shure: Or a story...
Shure:  然后来我们给评定
Shure: Then we judge...
Shure:  觉得这个故事怎么样
Shure: How good the story is.
Jake: 值多少个币是吧
Jake: How many coins is it worth, right?
Shure:  对值多少个币
Shure: Yes, how many coins.
Shure:  然后给他
Shure: Then give them...
Shure:  然后这个币
Shure: Then the coin...
Tasha: 像什么
Tasha: Like what?
Tasha: 一个故事换一根藤条的那种
Tasha: Like exchanging a story for a vine.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  然后这个币就用来拍卖
Shure: And then the currency can be used for auctions.
Shure:  接下来这些嘉宾带来的二手物品
Shure: For the second-hand items brought by our guests.
Shure:  以及是我们就是闲置的一些二手物品
Shure: And for some of our unused second-hand items.
Shure:  然后来进行这样的一个交换
Shure: We can use them for this kind of exchange.
Shure:  就是
Shure: I mean...
Shure:  也是跟这个环保理念比较比较挂钩的
Shure: This ties in pretty well with the environmental concept.
Shure:  行大概就是这个样子
Shure: So, basically that's the idea.
Jake:妙啊
Jake: Brilliant.
Katrina:  就是讲故事
Katrina: So, tell a story.
Katrina:  换了币然后就可以购买
Katrina: Earn currency and then you can buy.
Katrina:  购买他们自己带来的闲置物品嘛
Katrina: Buy the unused items they brought.
Shure:  每个人拍
Shure: Everyone auctions...
Shure:  拍卖就是比如说我
Shure: For example, I...
Shure:  我要卖一个什么东西
Shure: I need to sell something.
Shure:  然后我上来讲一下这个东西
Shure: Then I'll come up and talk about it.
Shure:  然后我认为他的起拍价大概多少
Shure: And I'll set a starting price for it.
Shure:  然后拍到这个钱
Shure: Then it gets auctioned.
Shure:  是给到那个拍卖的那个人的
Shure: The money goes to the person who auctioned it.
Shure:  然后他也流通过去那个货币
Shure: And that person gets the currency.
Shure:  然后我拿着这些货币
Shure: Then I take that currency.
Shure:  我可以再去拍卖
Shure: And I can auction again.
Shure:  你再去买别的
Shure: You can buy other stuff.
Shure:  对剩下的
Shure: Yeah, the remaining stuff.
Alice: 反正就是换了一种交流的货币
Alice: Anyway, it's just a different currency for exchange.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Katrina:  也构建了我们整个的经济体系
Katrina: It also builds our entire economic system.
Katrina:  哈哈哈货币流通
Katrina: Hahaha, currency circulation.
Tasha: OK那我就看他这个行
Tasha: OK, I'll check if this works.
Katrina: 我们都是那个市场的内部了
Katrina: We're all part of that market now.
Shure:  啊对可以把
Shure: Ah yes, it works.
Shure:  这些一起
Shure: All of these together
Katrina: 我们都是我们都是搞
Katrina: We are all, we are all doing
Lucia: 我们都是搞
Alice: 赚币的
Tasha: Making money
Katrina:  他是他是搞货币流通的
Katrina: He's, he's into currency circulation
Lucia: 可以做一些手工艺品
Lucia: We can make some handicrafts
Lucia: 用来用来拍卖
Lucia: To auction them
Jake: 对
Jake: Right
Katrina: 可以啊
Katrina: Yeah, we can
Katrina:  就我们做这个
Katrina: We'll do this
Jake:平台方
Jake: The platform
Katrina:  也可以
Katrina: That's fine
Jake:平台方和小店
Jake: The platform and small shops
Jake: 小店家
Jake: Small shop owners
Katrina: 对哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Right, hahaha
Shure:  今天就是这样的形式
Shure: This is the format for today
Tasha: 这是我的商品
Tasha: This is my product
Tasha: 我要拍卖了嘿嘿嘿嘿
Tasha: I'm auctioning it
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Shure:  还有什么想法吗
Shure: Any other ideas?
Shure:  大家我看看啊
Shure: Everyone, let me see
Katrina:  在那一天邀请他
Katrina: Invite them on that day
Katrina:  们过来这是我们准备的一些嗯东东西
Katrina: Over here, this is some of the stuff we prepared, um
Katrina:  那怎么招待他们要不要搞一点什么
Katrina: How to entertain them? Should we do something?
Katrina:  就像我我我经常我们学校草坪发
Katrina: Like, I, I often do this on our school lawn
Katrina:  他们会自己调酒
Katrina: They will mix drinks themselves
Katrina:  就自己自己
Katrina: Just themselves
Katrina:  人多的时候就有点像那种小party一样
Katrina: When there are a lot of people, it's like a small party
Katrina: 可以在外面
Katrina: Can be outside
Shure:  啊我可以可以给大家冲咖啡
Shure: Ah, I can make coffee for everyone
Shure:  我那有有一套手冲的东西
Shure: I've got a set of pour-over equipment.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina:  对就是可以请大家喝点东西
Katrina: Yeah, we can serve everyone some drinks.
Shure:  笑的这么开心
Shure: You're laughing so happily.
Jake: 突然开心了起来
Jake: Suddenly feeling happy.
Katrina:  支持
Katrina: Agreed.
Shure: OK
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 就表演
Katrina: Perform.
Shure: c加a coffee and alcohol
Shure: "C plus A" - coffee and alcohol.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 可以吧
Shure: Sounds good.
Katrina:  对那就是整个活动
Katrina: Yeah, that's the whole event.
Katrina:  那一天大概持续多长时间
Katrina: How long will the event last?
Jake: 一下午呗
Jake: All afternoon.
Jake: 一下午
Katrina:  嗯那就给他们提供一些饮品就够了吧
Katrina: Hmm, then just providing some drinks should be enough.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 先饮品然后我们就有点像
Katrina: Drinks first, and then we can...
Katrina:  这这算市级部分
Katrina: This counts as the city part.
Katrina:  然后饮品部分也有了
Katrina: And the drinks part is settled too.
Katrina:  那是不是还要什么节目啊您之前
Katrina: So, do we need any other programs? You mentioned before...
Jake: 嗯对可以
Jake: Hmm, yeah, we can.
Jake: 嗯或者最后一天应该是从中午
Jake: Hmm, or on the last day, starting from noon...
Jake: 中午管不管饭
Jake: Are we providing lunch?
Jake: 这个另说
Jake: That's another matter.
Jake: 也可以管也可以不管共多少个人
Jake: We can provide it or not. How many people in total?
Katrina:  好像
Katrina: Seems like...
Katrina:  不用管饭但是可以请他做一点点甜的
Katrina: We don't need to provide lunch, but we can offer some sweets.
Jake: 对对对下午茶
Jake: Yes, yes, afternoon tea.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Right.
Jake:嗯对那就是不用管饭
Jake: Yes, so no need to provide lunch.
Jake: 大家吃完饭过来
Jake: Everyone come over after eating.
Jake: 然后时间线我们捏一下
Jake: Then we'll finalize the timeline.
Jake: 如果是下午开始两点比如说或者3点
Jake: If we start in the afternoon, like at 2 or 3 PM,
Jake: 3点一直干到晚上之类的
Jake: we can work until the evening or so.
Katrina:  可以干到晚上但是天气怎么样
Katrina: We can work until the evening, but what about the weather?
Jake: 这个就不知道了
Jake: That, I don't know.
Katrina: 我看会不会下雨
Katrina: I'll check if it's going to rain.
Katrina:  不下雨的话如果像今天这种天的话
Katrina: If it doesn't rain, and the weather is like today,
Katrina:  弄到晚上还是挺漂亮的
Katrina: working until the evening would be quite nice.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 对今天下午的话
Jake: For this afternoon,
Jake: 这个小院子应该也挺舒服的
Jake: this small courtyard should be quite comfortable.
Jake: 你还还可以烧烤
Jake: You can even have a barbecue.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yeah.
Jake: 买签了吗
Jake: Did you buy the skewers?
Shure:  还没呢
Shure: Not yet.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 我今天一起购入
Shure: I'll buy them today.
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 还要买碳的
Jake: We also need to buy charcoal.
Shure: 签碳肉这些
Shure: Skewers, charcoal, and meat.
Jake:嗯嗯
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Shure:  其实就是外卖都有其实可以当日达的
Shure: Actually, we can order delivery; it can be delivered the same day.
Jake: 行行
Jake: Okay, okay.
Katrina:  21号
Katrina: The 21st?
Shure:  大家平时厨艺如何
Shure: How's everyone's cooking skills?
Shure:  就是会使用刀吗
Shure: Can you use a knife?
Katrina: 会啊
Katrina: Yeah, I can.
Tasha: 我还行呵呵
Tasha: I'm alright, hehe.
Jake: 会比较会使用
Jake: Yeah, I can use it well.
Shure:  能切个肉什么的吗
Shure: Can you cut meat and stuff?
修老板: 能切都能切吧
Shure: You can all cut, right?
Jake: 都能切
Jake: Yes, it can all be cut.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Jake:各位都能切了
Jake: Everyone can cut now.
Shure:  有大家这句话我就放心了
Shure: With everyone saying that, I'm relieved.
Jake: 因为你不切
Jake: Because you don't cut.
Lucia: 稍微冷藏一下
Lucia: Chill it a bit.
Lucia: 然后拿出来稍微放一会的时候好切
Lucia: Then take it out and let it sit for a bit, it'll be easier to cut.
Lucia: 嗯如果是软的肉我不是很会切
Lucia: Hmm, if the meat is soft, I'm not very good at cutting it.
Lucia: 就已经化好的那种
Lucia: Like the kind that's already thawed.
Shure: 明白
Shure: Got it.
Shure: 行
Shure: Okay.
Jake: 行可以烤是吧
Jake: Alright, we can grill it, right?
Shure:  可以烤
Shure: We can grill.
Jake:长春烤串
Jake: Changchun skewers.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina:  其实调酒好像就是买买一点那种
Katrina: Actually, for mixing drinks, it's like you buy a little bit of that...
Shure: 啤酒
Shure: Beer.
Katrina:  对然后搞一点冰块
Katrina: Yes, and then get some ice cubes.
Shure:  对
Katrina: Yeah.
Shure:  冰块的话
Shure: About the ice cubes...
Katrina:  哎我现在前面我们走两步
Katrina: Hey, in front of us, let's walk a bit.
Katrina:  不是有个咖啡厅
Katrina: Isn't there a café?
Katrina:  能不能问他们借点冰块
Katrina: Can we ask them to borrow some ice?
Katrina:  就不用自己买制冰机了
Katrina: So we don't have to buy an ice maker ourselves.
Shure:  可以
Shure: Sure.
Katrina: 我们花钱买点冰块
Katrina: We can pay to buy some ice cubes.
Shure:  那边有咖啡厅吗
Shure: Is there a café over there?
Katrina:  对啊昨天停车那位置
Katrina: Yeah, where we parked yesterday.
Lucia: 如果我们要求不那么高的话
Lucia: If our requirements aren't that high...
Lucia: 就是买一个冰膜然后自己冻一下
Lucia: We can buy an ice mold and freeze it ourselves.
Lucia: 也可以啊
Lucia: That works too.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia: 只不过就是冻出来可能没有哎
Lucia: It's just that freezing it might not
Lucia: 我们有透明
Katrina: Hey, we have transparent
Katrina:  我们有冰箱
Katrina: We have a fridge
Katrina:  就买个那个模具倒点水
Katrina: Just buy a mold and pour some water
Katrina:  前天晚上冻一下
Katrina: Freeze it overnight
Alice: 用蒸馏水就行
Katrina: Use distilled water
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh
Alice:：就煮过煮沸的水
Alice: Boiled water
Lucia: 哦可以
Lucia: Oh, that works
Shure:  蒸馏水对
Shure: Distilled water, right
Shure:  可还行呵呵呵
Shure: That's okay, haha
Shure:  我们到底是在搞什么
Shure: What are we even doing
Shure:  搞实验了是吗
Shure: Are we doing an experiment
Katrina:  那他整整体的时间流程呢
Katrina: So, what's the overall schedule
Jake: 比如说我们从入场3点3点开始吧
Jake: For example, we start entering at 3 o'clock
Katrina:  几点到几点干什么
Jake: What are we doing from what time to what time
Katrina: What are we doing from what time to what time
Jake: 对
Jake: Right
Katrina: 因为就5个人
Katrina: Because there are only 5 people
Katrina:  就有一点像那种市集
Katrina: It's a bit like a market
Katrina:  但是那种市集一般都是比较大
Katrina: But those markets are usually big
Katrina:  然后大家随意逛
Katrina: And people just wander around
Katrina:  但是我们这个地方比较小
Katrina: But our place is quite small
Katrina:  那你肯定要规定一定的时间干什么
Katrina: So you definitely need to set specific times for activities
Katrina:  一定的时间干什么
Katrina: Specific times for activities
Katrina:  要不然容易他们一下就看完了
Katrina: Otherwise, they might see everything too quickly
Jake: 对你的拍卖可以占一点时间
Jake: Right, your auction can take some time
Jake: 看占多长时间
Jake: See how long it takes
Jake: 然后
Jake: Then
Jake: 唉
Jake: Sigh
Jake: 就这些准备都是我们这几天准备对吧
Jake: So all this preparation was done by us these past few days, right?
Jake: 然后别的耗时间的短剧
Jake: And then for other time-consuming short skits...
Jake: 跳舞吗哈哈哈
Jake: Dancing, haha!
Lucia:  哈哈我一个人跳吗
Lucia: Haha, am I dancing alone?
Lucia: 可以拍一下
Katrina: We can choreograph a simple one.
Katrina:  以前也可以跳
Katrina: I used to be able to dance too.
Jake: 以前也可以跳
Katrina:  可以拍个稍微简单点的摄也可以跳
Katrina: We can film a simpler one and dance too.
Jake:硕也可以跳
Jake: Shure can dance too.
Lucia: 哦那也行对
Lucia: Oh, that works too, right.
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Lucia: 你如果有现成的剧本的话
Lucia: If you have a ready-made script...
Lucia: 我们可以拍一个哈哈哈
Lucia: We can film one, haha.
Shure:  演其实有有点小尬
Shure: Acting can be a bit awkward.
Tasha:  嗯不如跳舞
Shure: Hmm, better to dance.
Katrina:  因为那个音乐放上了
Katrina: Because when the music plays...
Katrina:  不如跳舞
Katrina: Better to dance.
Alice: 谈恋爱不如跳舞
Tasha: Dating is not as good as dancing.
Shure:  不如跳舞
Shure: Better to dance.
Shure:  捋一下时间线吧
Shure: Let's sort out the timeline.
Lucia: 可是跳舞的话戴眼镜会掉耶
Shure: But if we dance, the glasses might fall off.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 还戴眼镜那时候
Shure: Still wearing glasses at that time.
Shure:  那我们可以挑点简单的
Shure: Then we can pick something simpler.
Shure:  蘑菇蘑菇哎
Shure: Mushrooms, mushrooms, hey.
Lucia:  我们可以跳抖音上的那种
Lucia: We can dance to those TikTok ones.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  这个听我说
Shure: Listen to me.
Shure:  谢谢你
Shure: Thank you.
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 抖音上就大家都可以一起挑
Lucia: On TikTok, everyone can join in.
Lucia: 就是排的时间也会短一些对吧
Lucia: And the time to prepare would be shorter, right?
Lucia: 也没有什么比较大的动作
Lucia: Plus, there aren't any big moves.
Lucia: 戴眼镜也不影响
Lucia: Wearing glasses wouldn't affect it.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure:  捋下时间线
Shure: Let's sort out the timeline.
Tasha: 可拍满100个硬币
Tasha: We could film with 100 coins.
Tasha: 哈哈哈啊
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina:  你那个
Katrina: You know...
Tasha: 没事
Tasha: It's okay.
Tasha: 我只是觉得
Jake:哦好好可以买
Jake: Oh, okay, we can buy that.
Katrina: 你那个拍卖10个银币
Katrina:  拍卖之前首先要他们讲故事
Katrina: Before the auction, they need to tell a story.
Katrina:  才能获得那个币
Katrina: To earn the coins.
Jake: 对对对就是这个时间
Jake: Yes, yes, that's the time.
Jake: 可能就得放一个半小时了
Jake: It might take an hour and a half.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 就就你们昨天的那个活动
Jake: Like your event yesterday.
Jake: 也也
Jake: Also, also...
Shure: 也不用讲那么长
Shure: No need to talk that long.
Shure:  就讲一个小故事
Shure: Just tell a short story.
Shure:  一个每个人5分钟那种大概
Shure: Each person gets about 5 minutes.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Okay, okay.
Shure:  或者时间成本控制不好的话
Shure: Or if the time cost is hard to control...
Shure:  就以其他形式获得币
Shure: They can earn coins in other ways.
Shure:  但是这个活动的核心是那个拍卖过程
Shure: But the core of this event is the auction process.
Shure:  但是这个货币怎么获得
Shure: How they earn the coins...
Shure:  可以再进一步上去
Shure: Can be decided further.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 拍卖过程这个是要保留的
Shure: We need to keep this auction process.
Shure:  大概像9个人的话每个人5分钟
Shure: If there are about 9 people, each person gets 5 minutes.
Shure:  5945一个小时吧
Shure: 5945 in an hour, right?
Shure:  就按一个小时算的
Shure: Let's count it as an hour.
Lucia: 我给大家发一些币
Lucia: I'll give everyone some coins.
Lucia: 然后通过摇骰子让大家玩一会
Lucia: Then we can play a bit by rolling dice.
Lucia: 呵呵呵
Lucia: Hehehe.
Katrina: 这这像游戏
Katrina: This feels like a game.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Jake:呵整点游戏可以
Jake: Haha, playing games sounds good.
Jake: 可以我们门门口再来一个
Jake: Sure, let's set up one at our door.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: 没有没有开个玩笑
Lucia: No, no, just kidding.
Katrina:  没关系很快乐
Katrina: It's okay, it's fun.
Katrina:  确实啊
Katrina: Indeed.
Katrina:  这个听起来有点
Katrina: This sounds a bit...
Lucia: 哈哈哈一会发鸡蛋一会摇色子
Lucia: Hahaha, sometimes we hand out eggs, sometimes we roll dice.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈据点是吧
Jake: Hahaha, is this a base?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 一锅端了
Shure: Got them all in one shot.
Shure:  小心这
Shure: Be careful with this.
Tasha: 进来玩玩嘛
Tasha: Come in and play.
Tasha: 进来就可以获得10个币
Tasha: You can get 10 coins just by coming in.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure:  哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Katrina:  但是一一进来就让
Katrina: But once they come in...
Katrina:  就是刚开始肯定要获得货币
Katrina: At first, they definitely need to get some currency.
Katrina:  但是你获得货币
Katrina: But to get the currency...
Katrina:  是要他们通过讲故事的方式
Katrina: They need to tell stories.
Katrina:  但是他们一进来可能还没那么熟
Katrina: But they might not be that familiar when they first come in.
Katrina:  就要让他们在众人面前讲故事干什么
Katrina: So asking them to tell stories in front of everyone, what for?
Tasha:  那就自我介绍
Alice: Then just do self-introductions.
Tasha: 会冷场
Tasha: It'll be awkward.
Tasha: 可以获得一个币啊
Alice: They can get a coin.
Lucia: 啊自我介绍可以获得
Lucia: Ah, self-introductions can get...
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Katrina: 啊自我介绍可以获得
Katrina: Ah, self-introductions can get...
Jake:自我介绍获得或者
Jake: Self-introductions get or...
Alice: 第一个给5个
Alice: The first one gets 5.
Alice: 第二个给仨
Alice: The second one gets 3.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina:  养成机制
Katrina: Nurturing mechanism.
Jake: 或者我们其实在这个屋子里面
Jake: Or we can actually hide something in this room.
Jake: 可以藏点东西
Jake: We can hide something.
Jake: 然后
Jake: And then...
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah...
Lucia: 像复活节的那种寻彩蛋游戏一样
Lucia: Like an Easter egg hunt game.
Jake: 藏点币
Jake: Hide some coins.
Shure:  藏币
Shure: Tibetan coins
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Shure: 也行
Shure: That works too
Katrina:  就是刚开始自我介绍或者币
Katrina: It's like introducing ourselves first, or coins
Katrina:  然后玩玩点小游戏赢赢了的币
Katrina: Then we play some small games to win coins
Shure:  对就比如说
Shure: Yeah, for example
Katrina: 说一些问答什么的
Katrina: Like some Q&A or something
Shure:  野生动物拼图那个
Shure: That wildlife puzzle thing
Lucia:  哎问答的话反正是世界地球日
Lucia: Hey, if it's Q&A, it's Earth Day anyway
Lucia: 对可以
Lucia: Right, that works
Katrina:  知识问
Katrina: Knowledge Q&A
Lucia: 对答知识问答
Lucia: Right, knowledge Q&A
Shure:  知识问答得币
Shure: Knowledge Q&A for coins
Shure:  对对对对对
Shure: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Good
Shure:  世界第一
Shure: The best in the world
Shure:  我想怎
Shure: I'm thinking
小薇在哪一天
Tasha: Which day?
Lucia: 先要把那个二十几来着
Lucia: It has to be around the 20-something
Lucia: 二十几来着
Lucia: Around the 20-something
Lucia: 2222
Katrina: 钱给让他们得到
Katrina: Give them the money
Jake:21来着
Jake: 21
Katrina:  然后再开始推销
Katrina: Then we start promoting
Shure:  对
Shure: Right
Katrina: 推销我们的产品
Katrina: Promote our products